[Music]
it is day two of camera Matson's attempt
for world domination
yesterday he tried to become an American
Ninja Warrior hub we'll call it a
successful app okay listen for hours of
practice I made it about halfway through
the course not bad
okay but this you've been practicing a
lifetime for we are gonna help auntie
today with an old soap opera buddy of
cams Ken kam outrace josh duhamel in a
Maserati
[Music]
all right we are here Willow Springs
International Raceway we're in the
elements the winds blow we got racecars
going all over the place and most
importantly Josh Duhamel car racer
extraordinaire yeah
told me what you told me we were going
miniature golfing God exactly it's Josh
against me dueling it out on the track
Karen you're gonna eat my dust
bring it on JD bring it on I had reason
to be confident thanks to time spent
four days earlier with a secret weapon
oh that's my instructor the location a
trap in West Palm Beach Florida with a
maserati racing instructor by the name
age Ho Chi Minh forwards forwards slow
in fast out slow into a turn fast out of
the turn
sir Josh I got the Intel as for my
competition Josh is often flashed his
need for speed in the Transformers
franchise
in the audience for the fifth
installment maybe his son Axl I'm still
on the fence on whether or not I should
bring him I mean three and a half people
what do you think if you look too young
I don't know I'm gonna take him why
we're taking I made a man for life he'll
be fine as to the business at hand you
think this suit is gonna make me go
faster what is this by the way and are
you wearing underwear on anything I'm
completely naked under here my friends
call me grandpa because I Drive so
slowly so this is gonna be this isn't
gonna be much of a competition I'm slow
playing you because when I get out there
I'm gonna beat you exactly right we
complete that pages with us in the car
for the first race up first Josh in the
hot lap eight turns in 1.6 miles
top speed 115 miles per hour whoa you
said you were a grandpa driver me oh
you're up now it's my turn teach grandpa
a lesson
left
but Josh takes it just over a second I
go first on the next test the swole Josh
is off like a banshee and he wins
Carolyn the final test comes with a
twist a slalom driving backwards
[Music]
[Music]
for the last half grandpa takes a little
shortcut whoa God I crushed that last
one in my cone I win by over four
seconds so I'm the overall winner right
so it looks like the official winner is
Josh Duhamel what I guess it looks like
a ham can't beat me in the Maserati
right yes it does
congratulations man that was a lot of
fun thank you oh that did hurt because
that's your boy go way back knocking
Lonnie I wanted that one I know you
wanted that one
[Music]
you